pour nadège où en est la mobilisation
pour ce matin mais écoutez mine ils sont
à plusieurs de gilet jaune avoir appris
le départ 1 depuis la porte de
champerret 1 pour déambuler dans les
rues de la capitale pour l'acte de 62 en
direction de la gare de lyon alors pour
cet acte soissons de la préfecture de
police a mis en place un dispositif de
police assez important elle craignait
mais la présence d'éléments radicaux et
je peux vous dire qu'ils sont plusieurs
dizaines d'individus cagoulés habillés
habillé de noir à avoir un prix à le
départ 1 au sein de ce cortège ils sont
à présent alors pour l'instant pas deux
alors pas de d'affrontements particulier
tout se passe dans la bonne humeur
leschi les jeunes qui continuent et bien
de scander des slogans hostiles au
gouvernement des menus et le maquereau
style également au ministre de
l'intérieur d un slogan anti capitaliste
également que vous entendez et puis on a
des journées bien qu'ils sont là pour
protester contre la réforme des
retraites mais pas seulement ils sont là
et bien on pourra et bien à maintenir la
pression sur le gouvernement 62e samedi
de manifestations à d'affilée depuis le
17 novembre 2010 huit manifestations
donc dans le calme actuellement sous un
beau soleil et puis nous sommes avec
jérôme rodriguez figure du mouvement ddj
les jeunes ils sont nombreux les chez
les jeunes avant a pris le départ de
cette manifestation quelconque à quoi
vous attendez aujourd'hui écoutés
châssis surpris de par le monde et
surtout de par les accents c'est à dire
ce matin en arrivant sur la manif
j'ai énormément de bons jours mais de
partout en france du sud de l'est de la
france donc regain de confiance regain
de motivation quand j'entendais des bons
jours de moselle des bons joueurs de
montpellier des banques
toulouse et bonjour de de normandie le
btp s'est joint à nous on a des
syndicats derrière donc on voit qu'à
défaut d'être un un mouvement gilet
jaune on est un mouvement citoyen de
mécontentement sur divers sujets qui ne
vont pas en france et tout le monde se
rejoint en tous cas à l'échelle de cette
manifestation dispositif d suffit de
sécurité est très important on a déjà
constaté qu'il y avait plusieurs
dizaines d'individus cagoulés habillés
de noir c'est rassurant effectué
beaucoup de deux crs comme ça autour de
ce cortège vous parle à titre personnel
non moi ça me rassure pas j'en suis déjà
à de contrôle donc la répression
continue je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus pour attiser un petit peu la
nervosité et faire en sorte que sa part
dans un climat de violence je le
rappelle voilà on est materner on est
menacée on est sur une nasse mobile je
vois pas l'interet donc on peut plus
manifester démocratiquement parlant et
ça peut engendrer des fois de la
nervosité j'espère qu'on n'en arrivera
pas là si vous vous êtes capable de voir
qu'il ya des gens qui sont peut-être
dans le petit deux de [ __ ] le boxon ya
des policiers qui sont là à eux
d'interjet d'intervenir mais n'y a pas
de raison pour l'instant ça se passe
très bien on va peut-être sur la
dernière déclaration d' emmanuel macron
il ya il a dit que les l'intrusion des
manifestants a aussi au sein du siège de
la cfdt à paris c'était des violences
c'est une honte en fait ces violences
étaient une honte pour la démocratie
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire par
rapport à ça félicitations aux syndicats
ça fait plusieurs semaines que je prône
une gilet jaune isation du mouvement d'
arrêter cette forme institutionnelle qui
est de grève piquet de grève
assemblée générale et d'aller là on les
attend pas et je vois que ça prend la
mayonnaise ça le prend beaucoup en
province on voit des syndicalistes aller
dans les centres commerciaux
allez sur des péages et à paris ça
manquait donc on voit aujourd'hui il ya
blackrock aussi où on a été à blackrock
ils ont été à la cfdt ses marques en ont
fait parler d'eux c'est non violent ça
pas de manifestation ça embête personne
à part le personnel de la cfdt
moi je dis bravo les gars continuez la
tue ce qu'en pense macron je m'en fou ce
qu'on pense berger je m'en fous
aujourd'hui les gens ont besoin de
revendiquer et s'ils sont pas contents
eh ben on arrive à se forme d'actions si
vous voulez pas cette forme d'action
soyez à l'écouté des gens qui marchent
dans la rue un mois également peut-être
jérôme sur l'arrestation de tabous hcr
au théâtre des halles surprise vous en
pensez quoi de ce à bas la répression
continue il ya un an n'a rien on avait
fait une conférence de presse où j'avais
averti les journalistes que ce serait
bientôt leur tour on voit le nombre de
blessés journalistes aujourd'hui on voit
le nombre de journalistes arrêtés
voilà bon que quand on entend macron
vouloir mettre un contrôle sur sur le
journalisme et les informations qui sort
bah voilà où on en est les gars
bienvenue au club
parce que il ya un homme invité sur les
plateaux quand on entendait des
journalistes faire frapper par des gilet
jaune
mais quand on voit les policiers ce que
des policiers frapper les journalistes
là c'est marrant la corporation ne
marche pas on n'entend pas parler qu'ils
ont sur pas mal de plateau men string de
loyer il ya des policiers qui agresse
aujourd'hui des journalistes regrettable
ça marche toujours dans un sens pas et
puis alors même les violences policières
ça revient aujourd'hui sur le ces
experts qu'on écoutait il ya un an
disait que c'était légitime qui
aujourd'hui ils retournent leur veste
c'est marrant c'est très marrant donc
voilà donc laissé l'on parlait non c'est
ce qu'on veut on a des choses à proposer
on a des choses à revendiquer on
continue le combat on continue la lutte
parce qu on a bien compris que mâcon
était là pour rester encore dix ans et
c'est pas du tout dans notre intérêt
as tout dit jérôme non quand vous l'avez
entendu mais jérôme rodriguez il est
bien se satisfait de ce regain de
mobilisation et s'ils se satisfait aussi
de l'arrivée de nombreux chez les jeunes
à travers les occupe depuis les quatre
coins de la france alors pour on est
toujours ici en direction de la gare de
lyon donc on voit la manifestation qui
se déroule dans le calme jusqu'à présent
juste ici merci beaucoup à nadège
abderrazak qui suit donc pour nous ce
62ème acte d gilet jaune
[Musique]